APIECE.
I TRELY O
THEM MORD MORE AS  BVERELY DEFT.
WHAT HAS IE ON
>> Reporter: HI E, PAMELA.Y SEV
AND MISSILHE
RUNS THEY PRETTY MUCH
CAME IN TWO WAVES.ERNIGHT USING
INIANS SAY THEIR AIR
FEST
BALLTIATTACKS AND E WERE
UKRAINNS       S THOSE
SHAL
OUT BUT NEVERTHELESS, OF COURSE,
FOR E FOLKS WHO CIFRENEDTERRIFI
THEIR LIVEAS RUSSI
ANOTHESSIV ATTACK ON
SHOOT DOWN ALLALST AIR DEFENSE T
MUCH LES FCAPITAL,ANS FORCESSEEI
COUNTEROFFENSIVE
THIS WEENDINE'P
ER
HOWCASING
MODERN WESTERN WEAPONS WITH A
>> Repr:SES TO TAHA
GUYS
MINISTRY.WE HAVE R MOTIVATION, A
DR LAND.
THIS IS OUR NATION, OUR
THEY STRAININGM ARD ISTENS OF T
EVACUATSUALTIESNOW THEYBOUND TO
HAVE IN THE TOUGH BATTLES AHEAD
FOR THE UKRAINIAN ARMED
VERYYI IT WILL
ALL OSSIVE COUNTEROFFENSIVE
TERRITORY ING  ARE ALREADY SEE
TO BE STEPPING UP  POSSIBLE RUS.
KRAINIAN MISSILECIALS
T TARGETAROUND
MARIUPOLN SOUTHEASTERN UNE
T DAYS.
'SE
ADVISER TO UNESINCNGLISH ]
EVERYTHING THAT
IS PRECURSCOUNTERAAC
PRECCOUNTEROFFENDIVE.G NON-ENGL
IT WILL END UNDOTEHE
BORDERS OFKRAINE AS
IN 199THUPATION OFCRIMEA AND WEM
BUT FOR NONS
Y E
CITHESNEWLYWEDS JUST
TIED THE KNOT ON TEN THE AIR
IRENS WENT.
SO TONTINUED TBRATE IN THE BOMR
VOWING NSSIAS RUIN
THEIR LIVES.
AND, YOU KNOW,THE RESILIENCE WET
EO IN KYIV,  THEFF
THEY DO RUN TO THE
SHELTERS AND RUN FOROVY EMERGE
COMES IN AND GO ABOUT THEI
DAILY LIVEGHT BACK
MILITARY INTELLIGENCE  E'S
BELIEVE THEY CAN SCARE THED KYI
MISTAKEN, PAME YOU, ED, E MINIS
PUTIN FIRST BECAME PSI
INCIRCLE DEMONSTRATINGNE, WHAT
THR NERVOUSNESS.
THEY
THEY AT AND SIVE OPE
THEY'RE TRO SOMEHOW TO
PATIENCE ON AND EVER IER
HOPRUSSIANSIN
SUCCESOF COUEROFFENSIVOPERN.KRAS
PIEDER
HACKS
BY-U
RUSSIA.
WHATT DO THOSEKS
HAVE ON PUTID THE RUSSIAN PUBLI
MITTEDY GOVERNMENT, BUT
COSE KIND L RUSSIA, OFATIONS O
CONTROOF
RUSSIA OR RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES
SOME
KINDNG RUSSIANND ALS
MONSTRATION THAT
RUSSIA IS NOD H
AS PT DECLARED FOR
CASE, THATY AN THE, R R HIS , B
RITHAT LL BIN E IN GOOITH?
RIGHT NOW,T WANT  WITHDRAOOPS FO
TERRITORIES.HE WANTS TO STOP
HEDSE  THAT
RESTRUCTURE THE ARMY ECONOMY
FACING PROEM
>>TAND.
T ALL, FROM THE PERSON THAT
YOITH BACK IN TH
2000s? OH,ETELY DIFFERENT
AT THAT TIME WHEN WEGETHER FIRS
PRE  EXCSI OF
TWO REFORMS.
ADMINISTRATIVE REFORM, WHICH
MEANREN OF STATE  IN THE PUBLIC
E THE SECOND RM
WHICH MEANS JUSTS
NOPR
KGB AGENPENATURAL TE FACS AL
TIME.ANK YOUCH FORR
RECIATE IT.>> THANK YOU.
>>> AND NO ERAL OF 7th ARMY.
THER
KASYAN HOWVOOUY , WHAT
WITH THOSE STRIKES?
INV FEWITH TBODY AND T
ZAERE'S BEENIS FIELDER
INTERNET SAYING THATNT THARUSSIR
KAID BUT MORE
INOMROL STRUCTURE TW
POLITICAL LES V AND
FRONG GENERALS ALL
ON.
>> A THERE'S REPORTING OUTTHEREN
THE SHOWHEOME
RUSSIA.S OF DOLLARS CE I A FOR
U F ?
RUSSIA AND THEY ARE RUNNING OU
BUTRUNNING OUT FOR A LONG TIMEO
DOLLARS.
THE MISSILES THA LSLION
DON PY S REALLY IS
LOSTD A RACE
CHVANTAGE AND I
ACANES IN LAST NIGHTTRIKES
THE EVENING ANILES DURING THGAI
TRNG TO GET THE FASTER MOVINMOR
G SHOT
INOCATIO
UKRAEMPTING TO
WITH THEMAND COL AS
TROOP VE UKRAINEIT'S A BACK AND
BEC HETING A LOT OMI>> WTHE TRSS
YOU'LL RECALL THERE WAS  MBACK R
FROMHE ADMIN PATRIOT MISSILES.
THERE A
THEY'RE USING
IF YOU HADHE SAVINVES.
WAS ABOUT  SRT WOULD YOUBE LOOKE
HERE'S A
STE THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYS  THIS LI
COMMANDERS AND O NTHS ANDEY
HAVE BEEN IN
BATTLEFIWE'VE USED THAT TERME
TIMES ON HERNOW IT'S TIME FOR T
PRESIDENT AND  HEY
ED
BATTLEFIELD.
HERE'S WHERE T R
WEAK.
HE
UKRAINIAN THEY ARE AND WEEK AO
MENT THE BESND T THEY'RE GOING
TO TRYDECEIV
WHERE TH WHAT ES THEY'LLSE